der Vater eines der Opfer von Brokstedt
die dort bei der Messe Attacke im
Regionalexpress ums Leben gekommen ist
getötet ermordet wurden von einem
Staatenlosen Palästinenser so im Moment
der Stand der hat in dieser Woche den
Satz gesagt wenn die Haustür offen steht
da muss ich doch wenigstens gucken wer
reinkommt zu mir die Haustür steht offen
da waren wir uns gerade einig und sie
sagen trotzdem nee also welche Profiling
ich möchte gar nicht wissen wer da
reinkommt einmal aller Anteilnahme und
äh Ergriffenheit ob dieses schrecklichen
Verbrechens gibt es erstens einen
funktionieren Rechtsstaat und zweitens
müssen natürlich die entsprechenden
Verfahren auch regulär umgesetzt
funktionierenden rechtssta ganz kurz sie
sie bleiben beim Wort aber
ein funktionierender Rechtsstaat der
massenweise Menschen rein lässt sie
nicht kontrolliert die illegal einreisen
und anschließend auch nicht abschiebt
aber
Illegalität oder Legalität wird doch
während des Verfahrens festgestellt das
sieht man noch niemand an der
Nasenspitze an und das ist doch das
Kernproblem könnten es kontrollieren
aber das sollte ja nicht in Deutschland
sein
der europäischen dafür hat man noch die
Verfahren sozusagen in den Ländern wo
die
Asylsuchenden dann die Europäische Union
betreten dafür ist es so geregelt das
ist sozusagen Dublin 2 an dieser Stelle
und es ist in der leider in der
bestehenden Form nie wirklich umgesetzt
worden nie so ausgebaut worden dass die
Verfahren tatsächlich ausgereift sind
und so dass es dann auch zu einer
solidarischen geteilten lassen sozusagen
kommt das ist das Kernproblem über das
wir reden und deswegen haben natürlich
sie z.B in ihrer in ihrem Landkreis auch
das Problem dass sie vor allem
Deutschland ja auch als ein Land wo
besonders gern sozusagen oder viele
Menschen hinkommen weil sie hier erstens
eine Infrastruktur finden viele
Verwandte haben und so weiter und so
fort dann eben auch bei ihnen im
Landkreis auch schlagen so aber wenn man
eine solidarische Lastenverteilung
redeten auf europäischer Ebene und das
müssen wir machen an dieser Stelle dann
sehe natürlich die Situation auch anders
aus weil dann zum Beispiel auch Ungarn
in der überreden müssen in Europa sie
sind
EU-Politiker wir müssen das Problem
lösen wir müssen es machen und das
schaffen wir einfach seit vielen Jahren
mittlerweile nicht reden tun wir da
mittlerweile seit 2015 zwei 16 drüber
Herr Gräber sie haben wir sind gerade an
dem Punkt wer heißt da eigentlich ein
sie haben genau dazu recherchiert und
haben recherchiert dass die
Bundesregierung ja selbst Scharia
Richter aus Afghanistan importiert habe
wie kommen Sie darauf ja das ist eine
ganz interessante Geschichte die uns
auch als wir zum ersten Mal davon gehört
haben ganz schön überrascht hat weil wir
reden ja gerade über das Problem von
illegalen einreisen und sind tatsächlich
die sind die Reisen erstmal alle illegal
ein der kann es Übertritt ist illegale
wird bloß nicht verfolgt und
sanktioniert und dann stell die meisten
eben hier in Asylantrag in Deutschland
und da kommen ja auch schon inzwischen
wieder sehr viele aus Afghanistan die
irgendwie Schleuser bezahlen oder wie
auch immer die herkommen zusätzlich
genießen wachsenden zahlen die für die
Kommunen einfach eine Belastung sind und
die auch für die gesamte Gesellschaft in
Deutschland ja irgendwann muss man sich
ja auch mal die Frage stellen wohin das
alles führen soll
eine Belastung sind zusätzlich dazu hat
sich die Bundesregierung
so eine Aufnahmeprogramm ausgedacht dass
man jeden Monat bis zu 1.000 angeblich
bedrohte Afghanen noch zusätzlich legal
nach Deutschland holt da geht dann alles
angeblich eben überstürzt dort die
bundesverantwortung genau aus
Verantwortung dafür was man da
hinterlassen hat und natürlich gibt es
dort etliche Leute die auch mit äh es
geht ja nicht nur um die sogenannten
ortskräfte das geht auch um um einfach
laufen
und in diesem Programm das richtet sich
auch an an justizangehöriger also da
hatte man eigentlich im Kopf Leute die
dort am Aufbau des westlichen
Justizsystem beteiligt waren als Richter
und Staatsanwälte und jetzt von den
Taliban verfolgt werden den hat man zum
Teil auch schon sogar Aufnahme zu sagen
leben nicht in diesem Programm im
Vorgänger aber es ist ein Detail und da
hat uns jetzt ein warnscheiben indirekt
erreicht des deutschen Botschafters aus
der Botschaft in Pakistan die für diese
Prüfung zuständig ist und dieses
Warnschreiben also sowas habe ich noch
nicht gelesen und wir haben es von
jemand bekommen der sich mit sowas
auskennt der meint so was hat er auch in
seinem ganzen Leben noch nicht gelesen
das sind Botschafter in so deutlichen
Tönen warnt dass ich unter diesen
mehreren hundert angeblichen Richtern
und Staatsanwälten
etliche befinden die vielleicht mal ein
paar Tage Crashkurs im westlichen
Justizsystem hatten aber die eigentlich
von der Ausbildung haben als Koran
Schulen also das klassische radikale
islamische Scharia recht lernen zum Teil
mit Ehefrauen auf der Botschaft
erscheinen die voll Verschleiß sind und
sich weigern den Schleier abzuziehen
momentan ist für uns noch unklar wer von
denen wirklich schon reinkam es sind
vielleicht einzelne sind wir gerade dran
die Faktor ist es aber so die haben wohl
teilweise schon Aufnahme Zusagen
bekommen und sind jetzt im Prüfverfahren
und in der Botschaft vor Ort wo diese
Prüfung laufen
schreibt der Botschafter ans Auswärtige
Amt wie könnt ihr eigentlich was tut ihr
da eigentlich was glauben Sie warum so
etwas passiert
das ist eine gute Frage die stelle ich
mir auch und die hoffe ich dass ich die
Ihnen gemeinsam mit meinem Kollegen
Ulrich Thiele der der an dem Thema schon
länger recherchiert wir machen das
zusammen dass wir die Ihnen vielleicht
in ein paar Wochen beantworten können
was ist passiert nachdem sie das
publiziert haben im Cicero ist sofort
das Auswärtige Amt auf sie zugekommen
weil sie die Staatsminister und haben
gesagt Mensch wir brauchen sofort alles
dann Informationen wir müssen das wissen
was da passiert wir müssen das sofort
stoppen nein also vom Auswärtigen Amt
haben ihre Kollegen von Bild die das
Thema dann müssen wir teilweise
aufgegriffen haben eine Stellungnahme
bekommen ich warte heute noch drauf ich
und wir haben voraus haben wir noch
keine Antwort auf unsere Fragen bekommen
ich habe heute mal angerufen sie es muss
noch freigegeben werden da warten wir
mal ähm mal gucken also wir sind da
weiter dran in dem Thema und das mit den
Scharia richtig dann ist ein Problem es
gibt aber auch noch etliche andere sehr
merkwürdige Fälle
wenn wir wenn wir sowas hören das ist
jetzt eine Recherche das zieht so in dem
Fall und es ist ein jeder Ausschnitt und
gleichzeitig ich habe gerade schon
gesagt gibt es Berichterstattung über
all die Fälle derer die abgeschoben
wurden und wieder zurück im Land sind
beispielsweise es gibt die steigenden
Zahlen derer die eben illegal einreisen
wie kommt das in den Landkreisen in den
Orten in den Gemeinden an ja das ist das
große Problem dadurch ergibt sich
natürlich auch ein Konflikt innerhalb
der Gesellschaft man merkt das wir haben
das bei mir in meinem eigenen eigenen
Heimatort auch das sollten auch zwei
Turnhallen genutzt werden davor wurden
die genutzt für die corona-zeit also
Impfzentren ähnliches das sind ja
Sporthallen für Schülerinnen und Schüler
für Ehrenamtliche für Vereine und
deshalb kann ich das nur unterstreichen
solche Hallen dürfen nicht benutzt
werden jetzt ist es aber nur so ich
glaube zwischenzeitlich dass wir uns
viel zu sehr mit allen möglichen Ideen
befassen wie das in Europa lösbar sein
sollte was ja auch richtig wäre auch mit
Dublin 3 und allem ja wer es
funktioniert ja nicht und weiß nicht
funktioniert muss man sich auch mal
fragen ob unser Asylrecht in der
heutigen gerade überhaupt noch richtig
ist das ist ein großes Problem jeder der
bei uns den Fuß auf unseren Boden setzt
hat diesen Anspruch und darf ihn hier
mit einem Satz Ich will Asyl auch zum
Ausdruck bringen ich kenne Leute aus
Aserbaidschan ich bin Jude die gehen
aber jeden Tag in die Moschee bei uns in
der Vorderpfalz also sind sie ja Moslems
haben das aber angegeben sind seit 8
Jahren man muss dieses Asylrecht
überdenken das glaube ich schon und zwar
natürlich sehr human es gibt Länder auf
dieser Erde bei denen eine richtige
Verfolgung stattfindet nehmen sie mir
andere bei denen wir ja überhaupt keinen
Zuzug haben weil ja gar nicht rauskommt
während das jetzt hier in Afghanistan
natürlich an irgendeiner Stelle aufgrund
dieser schlimmen Situation von vor einem
Jahr irgendwie logisch ist helfen zu
wollen aber doch dann bitte nicht so mit
Kontingenten funktioniert das nicht
sondern sie müssen am Ende des Tages
schauen dass sie hier keine Anreize
bieten und dann will ich ihn einen Punkt
auch noch nennen wieso zahlen wir denn
Gelder an alle diejenigen die herkommen
da würden natural Leistungen zunächst
auch mal reichen ich frag mich immer
wenn ich Flüchtling wäre wer ich froh
ich hätte ein Dach über dem Kopf ich
hätte was zu essen und am besten
vielleicht tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit
integriert zu werden
das wird ausgetrickst immer und immer
wieder nein er wird er Einzelfall heute
Einzelfall benutzen keine das würde der
Einzelfall genutzt um das
grundlegende Recht auf Asyl was eine
historische zivilisatorische
Errungenschaft ist außer Kraft zu setzen
ja dass wir
bald auch nicht gesagt so
überarbeiteten aber in dem Sinne von
schon auch einzuschränken das ist ja die
Überarbeitung von der Herr Waldorf jetzt
gerade funktioniert an dieser Stelle ja
da muss man eben die Ressourcen dafür
zur Verfügung stellen dass es
funktioniert das wäre der erste logische
Schritt an dieser Stelle und zweiten was
jetzt gerade wieder passiert ist in
ihrer Argumentation dabei darf und ich
frag mich wirklich ob sie das ernst
meint ist zu sagen dass die Asylsuchende
noch erstmal auch mit irgendwelchen
Sachleistung abgespeist werden ich komme
ja immer vor dieser Debatte jeder
Situation wo 12 Kekse auf dem Tisch
liegen irgendwie da sitzen Bänker da
sitzen Hartz IV Empfänger oder wenn wir
jetzt ein bürgergeld-empfänger und
asylsuchen an der Banker nimmt 11 und
sagt dann zu dem Hartz IV beziehenden
pass auf der Asylsuchende wird dir dein
Keks wegnehmen und genauso ist dieser
Argumentation anstatt darüber
nachzudenken wie man zu einer gerechten
Verteilung sozusagen kommt angesichts
einer Situation in der Gesellschaft wo
so eine Ungleichheit herrscht und das
den Staat aus der Verantwortung zu
nehmen bei der wachsenden Ungleichheit
und so zuzuspitzen bei denen die nicht
zu haben das hätte ich wirklich für eine
fatale politische Richtung nichts das
geht darum dass ich einem Menschen der
Verfolgung hinter sich hat der
beeinträchtigt ist wenn wir der
individuell oder durch Krieg hier die
Möglichkeit gebe sicher unterzukommen
das ist doch die entscheidende Frage und
wenn Sie sich anschauen es gibt doch
diese Beispiele nicht nur eines in
Istanbul gibt es Reisebüros dafür dass
ich hierher kommen kann was machen die
denn und auch die in Afrika und wo die
schauen auf den Handys wo ich am besten
Leistungen erhalten kann warum kommen
denn die meisten Fälle weil
das ist ja ganz ehrlich mann das ist ja
Realität zu klären und dann wissen Sie
dass es so ist das muss man doch
überlegen das Einzelfälle oder ist es
mehr ein sind ja mehrere 10.000 wenn man
also wenn man so argumentieren wie sie
argumentieren wird jeder unter
Generalverdacht gestellt und das
widerspricht grundlegend den Zügen des
Asylrechts und ich sage noch mal
natürlich fliehen die meisten dieser
Menschen aus dem wirklichen Grund dass
sie von Krieg oder Verfolgung bedroht
sind und einfach Sicherheit so sagen ja
das ist auch so wenn die Leute Syrien
kommen
die Macht wieder übernommen haben dann
ist das so trifft ja nicht zu wir haben
ja Statistiken über die vielen Jahre und
wir stellen ja fest dass selten mehr als
50% anerkannt werden momentan
etwas andere Situation und so weiter
Türkei und so aber grundsätzlich wäre
eine nur bis zu 50% anerkannt das sind
mal bisschen mehr weil auch schon sehr
viel weniger das heißt 50% sind einfach
materielle egal da
das muss man mal sehen das ist überhaupt
kein moralischer Vorwurf denn ob jemand
flieht weil er erschossen wird oder
flieht weil er glaubt zu verhungern
56 Prozent im letzten Jahr glaube
44 % die Zahl kannten sie aber weil sie
sagten Einzel Einzelfälle
aus der Praxis sagen eine Abschiebung
also wir haben einfach zwei Sorten von
Asylbewerbern bei uns im Land die einen
kommen am langes Asylverfahren wenn
anerkannt die anderen kommen haben
langes Asylverfahren wenn abgelehnt und
bleiben auch da
eine andere Menschen gibt es nicht ich
habe in meinem Landkreis obwohl ich
eigentlich hinterher bin ich glaube im
letzten Jahr eine einstellige Zahl an
Abschiebungen gehabt weil mir nicht
klappt eine Abschiebung machen 100
Stunden
aber eine aber sie kostet 100 Stunden ja
daran beteiligt lange lange
verwaltungsvorlauf viel Polizei dann
wird man zum Flughafen gefahren Stadt
nimmt der Flugkapitän den nicht mit weil
das sagt er der will nicht oder er fühlt
sich auf haben Sie also sie sagten
gerade will ich gar nicht oder weiß ich
die Kosten gar nicht könnten Sie es
schätzen ja bald auf was kosten
Abschiebung
wenn er sagt 100 Stunden und dann wird
es nicht mit Mindestlohn bezahlt dann
sagen wir mal als wären 30 Euro dann
kann man es ja schon unbedingt also sie
müssen ja den Flug dazu
gemacht dass man nicht nur einen Flug
bucht sondern die Buchen ja dann gleich
mehrere Flüge weil sie ja nicht wissen
wann es funktioniert
helfen was kostet das ungefähr was sind
das für immense quasi in der nächsten
Runde die Abschiebung setzt ja auch viel
zu spät
das Problem mit Abschiebung zu lösen ist
übrigens auch in human also ich finde
das auch schlimm Leute erstmal ins Land
zu lassen ihn dann auch noch hier er hat
das Gefühl zu geben sie werden hier
umsorgt und
so dann und dann verbietet man ihn noch
das arbeiten weil wir im Asylsystem ist
soll natürlich auch nicht arbeiten ist
ja klar aber eigentlich wollen manche
arbeiten dürfen sie nicht das ist
teilweise wirklich absurd und dann Ihnen
nach Ew Empfänger Prüfung dann
irgendwann zu sagen jetzt setzen wir
dich in den Flieger und und müssen dich
mit mit Gewalt wieder zurück also das
heißt zurückführen Abschiebung ist nicht
das die Problemlösung ganz klar sie sind
bei der Grenzkontrolle bei der
Grenzschließung ja und zwar nicht nur
Grenzkontrolle sondern sie haben es
angesprochen Schließung der größte
Fehler von Frau Merkel war ja als es so
aus dem Router gelaufen ist damals 2015
und sie irgendwann gesagt hat jawohl wir
müssen ganz Kontrollen machen hat sie ja
äh hat sie ja es zurückgenommen oder
wollte nicht zustimmen dass man an den
Grenzen wenn man kontrolliert auch
zurückweist weil die Faktor diese ganzen
Leute die ins Land reißen haben ja de
facto eigentlich von vorne rein gar
keine Süden Anspruch weil sie aus einem
sicheren sicheren EU Nachbarland
einreißen und eigentlich spätestens dort
der Punkt so und wie bringt doch nichts
wenn wir kontrollieren und die
Polizisten nur sagen herzlich willkommen
in Germany hier geht's zum Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge sondern die
müssen natürlich auch die Leute
zurückweisen das hat sich Merkel nicht
getraut aus Angst vor den Bildern vor
den schlechten Fernsehbildern und das
das Problem haben wir bis heute wurden
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
nehmen unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie